[Music]
emma is with us emma is in orlando to
start off this hour hi emma how are you
hi dave nice to talk to you you too
what's up
um
so i am
i'm i just turned 20 i am moving to
orlando for my first job in the industry
and my job is going to require that i
travel around the city so
i am looking into getting a car
but i wanted to know what would be the
best way to go about that given my
financial situation give you money
yeah
yes i do how much money do you have
so i budgeted 10k for a car i already
have that in cash and that was the
amount that i was um
working up
to
i was working up to buying a car for 15
000
but i only have 10 000 right now and i
have another 10k in emergencies
in emergency savings
so
i
wanted to get a car that was around the
family of 15k because that would be the
one that would give me all the safety
features that i wanted and
um yeah but i'm in a position where i
need to get the car now
and
i don't know what to do about that if i
should be getting a cheaper smaller car
that probably wouldn't be too safe but
that would allow me to save up for the
more expensive one
or should i just go ahead and dip into
my emergency savings and buy the bigger
safer car now and then just rebuild it
from there okay what what is your income
um so the job i haven't started it yet
but i'll be starting within the next
couple of weeks it would be 60k before
taxes and you'll be doing what yeah
what's the industry
um engineering ah very good very good
and um
you so you've got an engineering degree
yes excellent way to go okay i'm gonna
answer your question and then i'm to
give you a smart alec answer too okay
okay can i do that
sure okay number one yes take five
thousand out of your emergency fund pay
cash for the fifteen thousand dollar car
five thousand dollar emergency fund with
you starting a new engineering job
making 60s gonna be plenty for right now
and then let's beef that emergency fund
back up
a little bit but you're not you're not
in danger by doing that okay so you get
your wish okay
now but the snarky part is you have to
learn this lesson
you cannot rationalize on purchases or
you won't make wise ones the statement
that the difference in safety of a
fifteen thousand dollar car and a ten
thousand dollar car is substantial is
absolute hogwash you just wanted a nicer
car and that's okay i think you can
afford it i want you to go get it i just
told you to go buy it but the difference
in safety of a ten thousand dollar car
or fifteen thousand dollar car doesn't
exist there is no difference in the
safety that's bull
okay all right so just don't you got you
have to watch doing that to yourself
because i do it to myself i did it for a
lot of my life and i'm 61 years old and
you're 20. okay so
uh
and as long as you tell yourself these
lies in order to get something that you
what just say out loud i just wanted a
nicer car and i have the money
and i want to know if it's okay to push
a little bit into that emergency fund to
do it i just want it but don't don't
don't tell me it's safety and don't tell
yourself more importantly than me that
it's safety because
you get you get slaughtered in either
one of them or you can just get bumped
into with either one of them and they'll
fall apart either one it doesn't matter
i mean
their differences are the difference in
type of car just take out the you know
a big suv
versus
john's tiny little girly prius
you know
the difference in that is safety okay
there's safety difference in those two
things but my fit i'm left here it comes
here comes no i'm saying my family
my wife and two kids drove that prius
for the last seven years and we actually
bought it from a friend of ours for ten
thousand dollars whoa you know what i
mean and so like the the car a ten
thousand dollar car was good enough for
my wife and kids until she said
i don't feel safe in a roller skate
anymore can we get something a little
bit bigger pregnant roller skate there
you go that's what we used to call it
that's right so all to say is for ten
thousand bucks
you can protect your family now that was
before the type of car is more important
than what it costs there you go for
safety yes the size how much metal is
around you the actual features and i
lost a good buddy in a two f-250 this
past year in a row so
living your life like that you're right
it's justification just say what you
want me go get it
but the
one of the things that when i went broke
him i had to learn it the hard way and
it just and i i and i can smell it a
mile away for that reason is
um we in america have almost no things
we need
most of our purchases are once
you've got a car i want a better car so
you don't really say out loud i need no
i need a third row no you don't no you
don't you want one be convenient nicer
you have a couch you want a better couch
and that's okay absolutely to buy some
wants but what you want to guard against
is to guard your heart against
creating these
narratives in your head that it's
required for safety
or it's required for uh so it's a neat i
needed it i was forced yeah i talked
about the other day you have to be
careful out there boundaries of the
abundance of the heart the mouth speaks
yeah talked to a guy the other day was
talking about he needed a new
hunting scope on his rifle oh definitely
said my granddad hunted for years with
just the iron sights man are you sure
well he might he might not be good
enough
that's true that's true he might not be
able to get anything without my websites
but you know what i really need what i
need
is i need some virtual drapes for my
virtual house steve but you virtually
wouldn't buy them at walmart you
wouldn't be more of a target guy i'm
more of a kohl's guy i wonder if owner
of kohl's has a virtual or target as a
virtual me i would buy mine at home
depot
me and home depot we're just like this
i'm just saying i've got tools i don't
even know what they do but i bought them
so because i needed them you needed them
so emma that's a good rant uh you're
you're a sharp young lady yeah 20 year
old engineer you've saved money you've
got a plan you're paying cash for your
move you're paying cash for setting up
your house you're paying cash for your
vehicle you're going to be a millionaire
hold on i'm gonna send you a copy of the
book baby steps millionaires by the way
the number one career in the millionaire
study that we did most likely to be a
millionaire you win the superlative
engineers engineers number two
accountants number three teachers number
four middle manager and entrepreneurs
and number five lawyers doctors didn't
even make the top five
they're number six wow that shocks me
there you go the mds mds are
classically known for not handling money
well yeah
pretty much like
music artists and stuff or nfl players
right i mean that kind of stuff right so
ah but hey they still made number six
they made number six so some of them are
doing it